muy buenas tardes a todos quisiera
comenzar esta plática haciéndoles una
pregunta porque el espacio porque
hablamos de exploración espacial es
porque gastar nuestro tiempo dinero y
esfuerzo queriendo llegar a otros
planetas pudiendo utilizar todos esos
recursos aquí para mejorar el nuestro
les voy a contar una pequeña anécdota
que me pasó cuando iba empezando a
adentrarme ya un poco más fuerte en el
tema del espacio era mi último año de
carrera
yo estoy estudiando ingeniería
mecatrónica
esta estaba en universidad estaba
leyendo acerca del espacio de la
tecnología que se está desarrollando que
está empezando a ser méjico o que ha
venido haciendo méxico y me topé con una
noticia por ahí del 2014 de que gméxico
para el 2019 iba a lanzar cinco robots
autónomos a la luna con una empresa de
eeuu para mí eso fue guau o sea es en
serio
llegué a mi casa
yo emocionadísimo a contarle a mi mamá
no para ponerles en contexto de cómo
reaccionen cómo reacciona mi mamá mi
mamá es del estado donde dicen que todo
es mejor ya sabrán ustedes cuál es y
saben cómo hablan de esas personas a
estas personas no te hablan te gritan
entonces llegué a mi casa súper
emocionado mamá mamá qué crees acabo de
leer que méxico va a poner 8 robots en
la luna yo en ese entonces estaba
trabajando con robótica en la
universidad también mi mamá se voltea y
me dice imagínense el acento no
porque méxico porque el gobierno va a
gastar dinero en eso habiendo tantos
baches habiendo tantas escuelas en mal
en mal estado faltan medicinas en los
hospitales y empezó no con una lista
impresionante y yo me quedé así de
ok yo iba empezando en el tema del
espacio
entonces me quedé callado realmente en
ese momento yo no tenía las herramientas
para decirle si mamá tiene razón pero
también el espacio nos ha dado grandes
beneficios hay dos etapas en la historia
donde se ha desarrollado más ciencia y
tecnología una es la guerra y la otra es
el espacio el 90% de las cosas que se
desarrollan para el espacio terminan
aplicadas aquí nos terminan beneficiando
a todos algo también por lo que a mí me
apasiona el espacio es
porque nos inspiran
el espacio desde el inicio de la
humanidad nos ha inspirado cómo se
movían nuestros ancestros los primeros
hombres a través de la luna a través de
las estrellas de los planetas fueron las
primeras investigaciones que se que se
realizaron el espacio siempre ha servido
de inspiración para todos cuantos de
nosotros de niños si nos preguntaban qué
quiere ser de grande cuántos de nosotros
nos decíamos astronautas por ahí
levanten la mano o cuántos de sus hijos
ahorita si les preguntan no dicen quiero
ser astronauta muchos estoy seguro no de
hecho hace poquito tuve la oportunidad
de practicar con la directora de una
empresa de aquí de grandes de mexicalli
estamos practicando el tema de educación
en baja california cómo podemos impulsar
la cómo agarrar esto el espacio como
inspiración para los niños y jóvenes
ya entrados en la plática me dice sabes
que federico si super está todo súper
padre mira sacó su celular y me dice ya
sabes que a los niños en kínder primaria
les dicen que se vayan disfrazados un
día de lo que quieren ser de grande sacó
su celular y me dice cuál crees que es
mi hijo era el astronauta
entonces el espacio siempre nos ha
servido de inspiración pero de qué nos
sirve todo esto no si se oye muy bonito
y todo la mayoría o muchos de nosotros
hemos soñado con eso pero de qué sirve
cuál es la ventaja del espacio que nos
ha dejado así como hay una lista de
cosas que podemos decir que en lugar de
invertir en el espacio hay que
invertirlo aquí el espacio nos ha dejado
de investigar investigaciones hacia el
espacio nos han dejado nuevos materiales
formas de energía
investigaciones médicas muchísimas cosas
por mencionar una del policarbonato el
policarbonato se hizo pensando en el
espacio utilizando utilizado para los
cascos de astronautas y ahorita muchos
de los que usamos lentes sus lentes ya
no son de cristal son de policarbonato
ese es una de las aplicaciones del
espacio
ahora hablemos de la economía espacial
el espacio es redituable si el espacio
redituable pongamos los números la
economía global del espacio equivale a
348 mil millones de dólares al año estos
son números del 2018 y va a ir creciendo
paulatinamente para el 2050 ya no vamos
a hablar de una economía global de
nuestro planeta para el 2050 vamos a
hablar de una economía tierra luna y
marte y eso es una realidad porque ya se
está trabajando en eso
para poner un poquito en perspectiva en
la economía global con que la podemos
compararnos ok 348 mil millones de
dólares que equivalen con que lo puedo
comparar el mercado global de
smartphones en el 2018 es de 120 mil 200
millones la economía espacial es casi
tres veces más que el mercado
smartphones a nivel internacional en
todo un año es redituable el espacio te
los dejo de tarea no creo de mi parte
que sí
el espacio muchas veces nos imaginamos
que lo que se nos viene a la mente a la
mayoría cuando hablamos del espacio no
se nos viene a la mente los satélites el
hombre la luna los cohetes el espacio
solamente en cohetes de la economía
espacial el lanzamiento de cohetes
solamente equivale a 4.6 mil millones de
dólares es un poco más del 1% es
prácticamente nada realmente la economía
espacial se mira se mueve más en la
industria satelital en los beneficios
que nos da la industria satelital que se
hace con los satélites
telecomunicaciones telefonía internet
internet satelital el que tenemos
nosotros en la mayoría no es satelital
entonces observación de la tierra clima
desastres naturales etcétera etcétera no
una de las aplicaciones que se le está
dando aquí en méxico
al espacio por medio de satélites es a
principios de año a finales del año
pasado no recuerdo bien la fecha la
agencia espacial mexicana
trabajo en un proyecto en el sur del
país donde se estaba detectando o
estaban apareciendo manatíes muertos por
allá por tabasco por allá por chapas
encontrando 50 de estos animalitos
muertos que pasó que se hizo para
determinar que les estaba pasando a lo
mejor la mayoría nos imaginamos que se
tomaron muestras del agua y se
analizaron etcétera etcétera pero no fue
vía satélite como se encontró que el
agua estaba siendo contaminada fue por
un satélite con ayuda de la agencia
espacial mexicana entonces la industria
espacial abarca muchos temas lo que más
nos está dejando sin duda es la
industria satelital pero vienen otras
pujando muy fuertemente en un futuro
vamos a escuchar de minería espacial que
es esto la minería espacial imagínense
cuántos asteroides cuántos planetas no
hay en el universo o en nuestra galaxia
asteroides que están llenos de minerales
que son tienen altos porcentajes de oro
de plata de cobre y otros minerales
otros metales que los utilizamos aquí la
minería espacial es algo que muy
probablemente a muchos de nosotros ya
nos va a tocar escuchar en algunos años
hablando de qué está haciendo méxico en
el tema espacial cómo puede méxico
involucrarse un poquito más en el tema
de desarrollo espacial méxico puede ser
una potencia a nivel latinoamérica y yo
considero que lo estamos siendo se están
desarrollando cosas importantes pero de
lo que más está desarrollen está
desarrollando ahorita es el tema de
pequeños satélites que son pequeños
satélites los satélites la mayoría
ubicamos lo que es el satélite enorme no
el que nos ponen en las películas pero
hay diferentes tipos de satélites desde
efectos satélites que son satélites de
no más de 100 gramos que de hecho se
están desarrollando hay una empresa aquí
en baja california que lo desarrollan
a mi empresa también de manera
particular estamos desarrollando estos
satélites después de los centros
satélites bien en los picos satélites
los nanosatélites los mini satélites los
micro satélites satélites medianos y los
satélites ya los grandes que todos
conocemos cómo está participando méxico
en el desarrollo de este tipo de
tecnología actualmente se están
desarrollando varios varios nano
satélites de universidades mexicanas en
conjunto con universidades de eeuu y la
nasa y la agencia espacial mexicana un
ejemplo de esto es el satélite que se
muestra en esta presentación el satélite
pipe méxico este es un satélite que está
desarrollándose está siendo desarrollado
por la universidad popular autónoma de
puebla la agencia espacial mexicana y la
nasa pero un dato curioso de este de
este satélite se les denomina cube sat
que son de 10 x 10 x 10 centímetros este
nanosatélite empezó a desarrollarse aquí
en baja california hace unos cuantos
años porque no lo terminamos porque
siendo el estado con mayor industria
aerospacial de mexico
dando el salto que nos está faltando
para terminar este tipo pero este tipo
de proyectos
cuando hablamos del espacio muchas veces
que nos imaginamos cohetes la mayoría
nos imaginamos cohetes el hombre pisando
la luna diferentes cosas muchas veces
extraordinarias que decimos no o sea
incluso en películas cuando hay un
problema muy difícil a lo mejor algunos
se acuerdan no se han dado cuenta dicen
no pues no es no es rock & science para
dar la solución a un problema como que
algo está muy complicado dicen a los
rockets i'm the rocket saints por lo
complicado que es pero el espacio no
siempre es tan complicado a veces
nosotros mismos estamos con ese chip de
que no eso es para países super
avanzados es de millones de dólares no
es cierto hay cosas tan simples en el
espacio que tienen que contemplar como
por ejemplo saben ustedes porque no se
puede comer sal en el espacio
alguien sabe no estoy seguro que la
mayoría de ustedes está pensando que
porque le pasa algo al cuerpo humano
si por ahí un poco pero lo principal por
lo que no se puede comer sal en el
espacio es por lo siguiente quiero que
se visualicen en su taquería de
preferencia
están a punto de comerse un taquito de
carne asada o un taquito de pastor o lo
que ustedes gusten o están por darle el
toque final y le van a poner un poco de
sal
visualicen agarrando el botecito de sal
y echándose lo a su taco
qué pasa acá en la sal en el taco que
pasa en el espacio la sal nunca va a
caer al taco
por algo tan simple como eso no se comen
sal en el espacio ni especias por la
gravedad qué pasa si en dado caso a
alguien o alguna vez una vez un
astronauta medio chistoso que se llevó
un sandwich en una misión espacial de
los transbordadores no lo reportó o no
dijo nada se lo llevó es quien de
escondido nadie supo cómo lo llevó se
llevó un sandwich allá soltó coronas
esas bolas pueden dañar los sistemas de
toda la nave incluso en un descuido de
los astronautas lo pueden ingerir sólo
pueden aspirar y puede causar problemas
de salud no por cosas tan simples como
esas es que no sé no sé no se come sal
en el espacio por la gravedad
principalmente y lo que podría ocasionar
a los sistemas
hay diferentes tipos de cohetes ahorita
la mayoría o muchos de los que conocen
un poco este tema están las las misiones
de los transbordadores espaciales
ahorita hay empresas como spacex que
están lanzando cohetes no de la nasa que
la nasa contrata sus servicios hay
diferentes tipos de cohetes cohetes de
combustible sólido combustible líquido
actualmente ya se está trabajando
combustible nuclear iónico de plasma
incluso antimateria son temas que se
están manejando en el espacio y por
poner un ejemplo todos están en fase de
prototipo pero
un gramo de bueno
la cantidad de antimateria del tamaño de
menem equivale a millones de galones de
combustible entonces imagínense que no
se puede resolver aquí en nuestro
planeta con ese tipo de energía
[Música]
les quiero platicar de una experiencia
personal
yo me apasiona el espacio aparte de
apasionarme de lo que se hace en el
espacio de lo que podemos hacer para el
espacio y de cómo nos beneficia como nos
impacta en el día a día estoy trabajando
en diferentes proyectos estamos
desarrollando pequeños satélites estamos
haciendo pruebas ya con cohetes de
combustible sólido aquí en mexicalli
hemos hecho ya algunos lanzamientos en
alguna ensalada tanto de pequeños
satélites como de cohetes alcanzando 1.5
kilómetros de altura con una carga útil
de 500 gramos
pero aparte de eso tuve el honor de ser
astronauta análogo del 15 al 30 de
diciembre del año pasado que es esto
participe en una simulación de una
misión a marte en el desierto ayuda
esta esta simulación fue la primera vez
que se conformó un equipo completamente
mexicano de jóvenes de entre 25 y 34
años todos tenemos ya varios años
trabajando en el tema espacial apoyados
incluso en algunas ocasiones por la
agencia espacial mexicana y estuvimos 15
días simulando que estábamos en marte en
la comida comíamos comida deshidratada
todas nuestras comidas estaban en botes
secos imágenes de pollo seco carne seca
todo seco todo lo teníamos que hidratar
entonces pues a lo mejor la comida no
estaba tan rica no pero
este tipo de simulaciones o de misiones
se tratan de validar la tecnología que
se está desarrollando la parte
psicológica también imagínense estar 15
días con los mismos changos
batallando con la frustración de que el
brazo robótico no está sirviendo el
rover no avanza no hay
telecomunicaciones
y no tienes con quien compartirlo
estuvimos sin comunicación con el mundo
exterior más que con nuestro centro de
control que es nuestro centro de control
lo que sale en las películas de houston
tenemos un problema pues nosotros
también lo teníamos entonces
en esta moto en esta foto que les
muestro era la es la base la estación
donde estuvimos durante 15 días nos
apegamos lo más que pudimos a una misión
a marte obviamente en temas de gravedad
y diferentes clima pues no se apega
tanto no pero se seleccionan estas bases
en estos lugares porque se acercan lo
más que se puede dentro de nuestro
planeta como dato nos bañamos una vez en
15 días
como nos vayamos como nos limpiamos era
con toallitas húmedas diarias pero
porque creen que nos bañamos una vez en
15 días fue navidad para sentirnos
guapos este nos bañamos porque en marte
solamente hay hielo en los polos pero no
hay agua entonces no vas a poder darte
el lujo de estarte bañando y al
principio a la verdad grande que si fue
como así me siento medio sucio pero
después algo súper importante del equipo
que se conformó que como les comento fue
la primera vez que fueron un equipo
completamente mexicano se llama mex uno
este todos sabíamos bien a que íbamos
todos sabíamos bien nuestra misión y por
qué estamos ahí
les comparto una foto del equipo no aquí
ya fue al salir de la misión después de
esos 15 días
no parecen creo que no parece tanto
estamos mal y decimos pero estábamos
increíblemente contentos por todo lo que
realizamos todo lo que validamos todo lo
que nos llevó el hecho de llegar ahí
realmente fue una experiencia increíble
yo veo el tema de la exploración
espacial les voy a poner un ejemplo
rápido muchos de ustedes a lo mejor se
preguntarán a mí me han preguntado mucho
hoy pero por qué queremos llegar a marte
porque exploramos de qué nos sirve qué
beneficios nos dejan
yo lo veo de la siguiente manera les voy
a poner este pequeño ejemplo rapidito
imagínense que yo con los varios kilitos
de más sin hacer ejercicio digo a mañana
voy a correr 10 kilómetros ni de chiste
no que tengo que hacer me tengo que
visualizar no pues ahorita no puedo pero
me voy a preparar para hacerlo en 6
meses pasan esos seis meses
corro una carrera de 10 km cruzó la meta
con que me quedo cruzar la meta
realmente el último que te vas a quedar
con todo lo que aprendiste y todo lo que
desarrollaste todas las nuevas
cosas que tú viste los hábitos que
tuviste que hacer para llegar a esos 10
km
cambiaste tu alimentación empezaste a
hacer ejercicio etcétera etcétera no te
cambio el cuerpo
de la exploración espacial es algo
similar no se trata nada más de llegar a
marte sino todo lo que vamos a tener que
desarrollar para llegar hasta allá y
como todo eso como nos vamos a quedar
con todo eso como todo eso realmente nos
va a beneficiar aquí
para terminar
quisiera comentarles que
realmente en el tema espacial aquí en
méxico nos falta mucho por hacer pero
hay mucha gente muy talentosa que está
haciendo grandes cosas está esta imagen
es de una de las entradas al hábitat que
estaban yuta al llegar allí todos nos
quedamos de que guau esa simple imagen
era un reflejo de lo que nosotros
sabíamos que tuvimos que hacer para
llegar ahí fue un no importa cuánto
tengamos que pasar pero lo vamos a
lograr y lo logramos
para terminar quisiera dejarlos con una
pregunta si a ustedes les parece después
de lo que les acabamos comentar que es
importante la exploración espacial
quisiera que se preguntarán que podemos
hacer nosotros como mexicanos para
aportar en el desarrollo de ciencia y
tecnología espacial en nuestro país y
cómo nos va a beneficiar en nuestro día
a día muchas gracias
[Aplausos]